then he goes oh you don't like nice guys
because you're always with these
[__]
and girls always they love that they
love the victims they love when you say
that and then they're proposing to get a
[__] NBA game yeah yeah and the
mascot's like yeah
[Music]
welcome back to a heartwarming episode
of the careful boys today we have
Colleen Jones Bart next Steve myself
I we have a question from one of our
esteemed followers her name's ryry and
uh she had a really interesting question
because she's actually in the situation
sorry if I just sold you out by saying
your name and make sure you join the
patreon because that's the way you can
have direct questions that we can
discuss on here and actually talk to
y'all too that's the access point thank
you for helping the show thank you so uh
how do you deal with being attracted to
your best friend you they're not your
best friend I never been you have a
hidden agenda right yeah I've never been
horny for Bart ever yeah that's like but
if you wanted the [__] Bart that would
be an ulterior motion so the best friend
thing is the only thing standing in the
way of you being horny for him nah I
just never found him attractive sorry
about her yeah have you ever found Joe
attractive maybe that'll help
only
no no okay dude we were like that means
you're friends we were in bikinis pretty
much we've seen each other naked still I
didn't want to [__] them you don't think
you got a hot bod no we went to we went
to a spa together I saw his dick and he
saw mine I saw your dick too what'd you
guys think we've all seen his dick not
once did I even have does it look like a
regular dick it just looked like a
[__] uni
a pretty nice fresh one
like a Hokkaido
what is uh what does Joe's dick look
like me too is it like Hannah's drawing
it's not that small is it to scale not
that small I did not see an erect one
yeah yeah I think Hannah's was erect oh
no it wasn't it was small mine was the
one that I saw was relaxing yeah
he was taking another vacation what if
you're one of your best friends and then
you're not initially attracted them at
all and then like as time goes you
develop an attraction well things change
yeah how do you deal with that I kind of
do that with Tiff we were like buds you
were like really good friends we were
very good friends but I would always
like throw out like you know some flirt
like but doesn't that also mean from the
start you already had a attraction I
always thought she was cute and I
thought we had great conversations about
stuff but like we she was like you know
talk to some other idiot and I was like
some I was like talking to some other
you know [__] yeah idiot you know but
has that ever happened to you guys where
you can build attraction like to me it's
always initial like I've I always have
to find them attractive somehow I think
physically is like the entry point right
for most people and then the more you
get to know them it's either less
attractive or more attractive oh yeah
that's how I am too yeah because it's
like there's some people that you think
are attractive and you start talking to
them you're like God damn they're
[__] like I kind of I kind of hate
you like I think you're a bad person you
know and then you marry them and then
[Laughter]
yeah but the
a little weird weird
because I don't know if you can be an
authentic best friend if you're madly in
love with them that's not a real
friendship unless there are 13 and all
of a sudden they developed into a person
that you are different than what you had
seen before that's true like if they're
both 13 and now they're both set I think
in this situation it's more about like
how do you navigate choosing between
like do I stay friends with this person
and just how and have a closeted feeling
about it you gotta shoot your shot or do
I yeah or do we shoot the shot and then
risk ruining it but being honest you get
another best friend it's fine yeah but
it's kind of hard being wet for someone
Non-Stop and then you're just hanging
out with them to me that's very
unauthentic that's torture dude that's
that's your own [__] version of hell
it is being soaked for somebody you
can't even [__] rub bellies together
nope the whole time you're thinking
about them entering you
oh
well you can't have ulterior motives if
you want to [__] them that's being a
[__] up prank you're being a bad
friend yeah that's what I think you got
to be like look are you gonna sit on
this face or what that's what you got to
do yep honestly she gotta She Gotta
[__] give him an ultimatum I mean
like hey dude let's do this what do you
mean by loot like ruining the Friendship
it's already been ruined because you're
wet for him exactly well maybe it's like
you're acting a certain way and then in
the Friendship because ultimately you
want to get their clothes off and you
want to lay them down and you want to
[__] bet them over and you want to
step on their [__] head yeah both
feet even and that's [__] up but what
if it's like a feeling that caught you
off guard with time huh what if it's a
feeling that catches you off guard with
time because sometimes you don't even
know and then you just go oh [__]
then you gotta have a [__]
conversation about it honestly also what
happens if she says something and she
doesn't wait a certain amount of time
for him to manifest those feelings says
what I don't know I'm just throwing a
hypothetical like she's too horny and
then he's like wait I didn't even know
you like me wait let me think about that
like if she comes up to me and she has
like one of those shoe measuring things
strapped at the back of her head
then I'm like
that I'm kind of like those what did you
play with when you're a kid with all the
sliders on oh dude then I'm kind of like
okay I kind of pick up what you're
putting down right now but at least
she's being forward with it and she's
being honest about the whole situation
you got shoes on or you you got foot
just the whole foot have you ever had
have you ever had a friend shoot their
shot with you after you guys were
already friends for a while yeah I feel
like every girl has a story like and how
did it go like what's a good example
first
because I know there's bad like has ever
been successful in that way um
but then
looking back on it I was just like um
always just stay
really why why tell us the details
because that's like it's like I think
guys that are in the friend zone right
now they're like there's a way out yeah
so show them the way out yeah
but the one that turned into a
relationship was more so like oh like
we're better off as friends as a
romantic relationship and having like a
future together it I couldn't see it
working out yeah yeah yeah
how come you gave him a chance yeah yeah
um because there was already like
Rapport there we already had like a that
friendship Dynamic did you find him
attractive at that time
um I found certain things about him
attractive
he got in yeah there it is and then what
yeah I mean that's going to be the key
factor with any like romantic
relationship right is you have to find
something attractive about them but but
did he
change the the friend Dynamic to now
like did he like openly talk about it
like what was the breakup see that's the
thing is it was never like an openly
conversation about like hey remember the
time where we were just friends it just
kind of like naturally progressed into
it were you like all of a sudden making
out you're like oh I guess we're here
now yeah that's exactly how it happened
so just you should realize you're in
reverse cowgirl all the stuff yeah yeah
all of a sudden I'm like I guess we
don't have to talk about it I guess we
are attracted to each other what's an
example of when a dude who is your
friend shot his shot and then it just
you should never want to see him again
it was like 85 percent of the time yeah
pretty much and that's how you what's
like your response to that no my
response is like obviously I'm more
empathetic oh so you're not like you
[__] it up man no now we can't do you
like I just find it it's hard to be like
okay well now let's just remain friends
because I feel like you have to go and
just
get rid of that idea that we're gonna go
something further yeah yeah yeah because
otherwise it's just like it's hard to
hang out with you in an authentic way
with me knowing that you won't yeah and
I'll tell you right now you'll never
convince a guy that [__] ever because
they'll keep they'll keep shooting their
shot I think that's what makes it scary
for guys to come out because they know
that like if you're losing this person
and then they almost like I'd rather
just be around you and be wet free but
they're gonna lose but this is a female
right you never go back from Hey I want
I kind of want to [__] you you don't go
back from that this is this is a female
right yeah yeah so then it's a it's kind
of flipped
like Sam are you saying like she has
more leverage in the sense that like
okay she kind of does have more lives I
think so I think I also don't know I
also don't know if this is a female to
male or female to female I have no idea
or if they're transitioning yeah I think
either way you got to just just put it
out there if you really want to be or if
you want to like attempt to be with that
person you gotta I think you gotta be as
transparent you got to be clear that's
good that's good with tax though because
some [__] are stupid as [__]
Legends like well let's put it out there
yeah like I love you so much
I was just putting it out there yeah
that is true that is bad that's a bad
thing every guy who comes to me and says
that I'm like instantly like absolutely
let's make this happen
she's so cool
[Laughter]
go to the holiday
that's a little too much uh
circumference for me see that's why I
know men don't rule the world because
that [__] doesn't happen does that come
in a medium
yeah tell me the size it's about it's a
healthy
just opening it up you take the shoe
measure dude that's like a meme right
there it's like it's like what women
think guys want and what guys want is
Parts [__]
that's the scenario that's the dream no
but I think that's the situation is like
their best friends
she's attracted she doesn't know if it's
worth the risk of like you're gonna meet
somebody else I like for me you're gonna
meet somebody else why stay in a
situation exactly but what if both
friends had the same time yeah you got
to find out that's why it's better to
have certainty than this like lingering
whatever yeah because once you like
someone I guess this is why I'm not I'm
never into these situations is because
once
that is like how I feel it's really hard
to live in that gray of like continuing
a friendship that isn't authentic
because in my mind I'm not being
authentic with this person anymore yeah
so then whether they reject it accepted
or whatever it might be uncomfortable
but then
if I have the self-control too maybe
like
like be okay with the fact that they
rejected me and then can I now shut down
my desire and then I can find them
attractive but then now like I can I go
back to that like that's gonna that's
gonna take time though too like like the
dynamic between it's not like somebody
you just found attractive and you've
been talking for a few months like this
is someone who's your best friend is
according to like the prom but guess
what this friendship is maybe the most
overrated Concept in the [__]
Universe when it comes to [__] like this
because all the friends I had like this
growing up that I didn't tell I didn't
shoot my shot with or whatever I don't
even [__] talk to them anymore yeah
just shoot your shot get it out of the
way and move on that's so true that's
very true yeah I mean like well I live
in purgatory yeah and also are you
really a good friend if you have such a
big secret with your friend yeah that's
exactly how I yeah it just doesn't feel
real No like is the friendship
authentic if you can't be completely a
hundred with them oh dude especially
your best friend yeah and also too you
always have to Ace up your sleeve
because you could be like look I think I
have feelings for you
and then if they say no there you go I
was just I was just kidding
I was kidding yeah I was playing I was
[__] up got you yeah there's a camera
over here
I can't believe you believe me you set
up cameras just to like cover your ass
you just cover your ass dude so I was so
we're gonna hang out tomorrow
I remember I was talking to this girl
um early 20s and she was super cool like
[__] rolled motorcycles and all this
[__] and then like
I was like damn dude you're like pretty
awesome
um and then like let's let's start
dating or whatever and then um like a
month later she was like oh I feel so
bad I'm like why she goes okay so I have
this like best friend I was super into
him I didn't know if he liked me back
and then he like noticed that we were
kind of talking and so
he felt like he needed to really come
out and say like I really do like you so
you don't lose to you yeah and then for
her I mean I at the time I was like I
get it you known this dude for years
and I wasn't even in that stage of
thinking about marrying her or anything
I was just in the like yo she's fine I'm
having fun yeah and then so
I was like wow that's crazy I didn't
really feel like
hey man you're supposed to be a me I
thought that was really cool because
that's sexy I thought I was like dude
you guys
in my head I was like you guys waited so
long for why because both of them were
afraid
um so they were on the same and I
thought that was her gay best friend I
didn't know he was into her but they
that was a that was a story of just like
this you know so insulting
what are you a gay best friend burn I
had no idea yeah and then so she was
like I think we're gonna really try and
like and then like you know I've been
you know I liked him he liked me back
and I think we just too scared to break
up the the best friend yeah thing and I
was like that's tight
but they both like each other that's
like a dream come true that's great
exactly I didn't have any attachment to
her like that I and then well that's
good that you came along and you were
like the time bomb for them to like get
their [__] out yeah because they're
[__] lacking so hard you were an
accelerator it probably made him feel
threatened like oh [__] like no [__] you
[__] gay best friend yeah
so that's bad branding you gotta be
[__] most cases that doesn't happen in
most cases I hear mostly guys in love
with a girl and they're making it up in
their mind that's the biggest case I see
you you're watching this I see you and
then they pour out their [__] heart
and the girl's like you manipulating
sack of [__] I was I thought we were
friends I confined it into you and then
and he goes oh you don't like nice guys
because you always put these [__]
and girls always they they love that
they love the victims they love when you
say that and then they're proposing to
get a [__] NBA game yeah yeah and
then
[Laughter]
but on the flip side I haven't really
heard many like instances of girls being
fat like they're like the best friends
they have a secret crush and then they
like the guy because that's the only
example that I remember clearly of uh it
might like like experience right I don't
have any female friends that are like
that because I think when they get along
with a guy like heavily it's probably
because of Attraction 100 dude I had a
chicken High School who was in who's my
friend who was then told me she was into
me and it was weird after that straight
up because I wasn't into her at all and
it was just like straight up strange
after that yeah weird weird Vibes must
be nice dude
but we don't know the dynamic between
her I didn't take advantage of anything
yeah we don't know the dynamic between
her and her like best friend right but I
kind of feel like the best policy is to
be authentic and and like ruin the
relationship it's not a real
relationship it's not a friendship
anymore I would like to know how
different it is when it's two girls like
what that I bet it's the same I bet it's
very similar but you know like women are
just better I know women dude I know two
girls I know two different girls have
dated each other and they I don't think
they were best friends already
they were best friends they're best
friends and then they and then they
[__] and then they were lovers for a
while huh and then they make it all the
way through
yeah enough long enough they were they
were together for a while you know but
then but like women are such better
communicators I wonder if it's like an
easier time and sign readers too so I
feel like the chicks they probably even
know each other that they like each
other somehow yeah but they also they
also think more than guys so they might
they might overthink the situation
that's true they also tell secrets and
[__] better than guys do oh that's true
yeah but high school girl friendships be
looking kind of gay yeah they get
jealous like they like don't hang out
with her too much and I'm like damn
you're so you're like a jealous
boyfriend what the hell is wrong
like mother Henning like they're like
they're close yeah they're like the way
that they're close it's like are you gay
if you call them gay then they'll stop
him from doing that I think that is a
big thing and then they [__] make out
at parties and then it's like yeah I
hate it I get so bad that is a big thing
though where there's like a
possessiveness where like some girls
they don't want you they like seem like
a door right in between they're like
sister lovers because they don't want
you to take away their like their their
fun you know yeah that's true and then
little girls be like [__] locking arms
the whole day through cuddling and [__]
guys do the same Saving Silverman type
[__] too I was into this chick from like
[__] middle school or no High School
freshman year all the way till like
forever basically like like till um gosh
I got with like two girlfriends ago but
like that was like I was in her for like
a decade almost right but yeah it was
just never like the timing was never
right and it was like all that
unrequited love [__] stuff that you
build up in your head and then like
the time that she told me that she was
in love with me I was with this other
chick and I'm such a loyal ass [__]
that I was just I just stopped talking
to her straight up and then we
reconnected a couple years ago yeah it's
a breach and I'm like I'm not gonna be
[__] up but I'm not gonna ever do that
to somebody right and then um
yeah just never quite lined up but but
that was I know that I wasn't being a
good friend to her right because I had
those ulterior motives that's why I have
such a strong stance on this topic
because I remember those feelings and
how that was and how I would pick up the
phone and all this other [__] and being
such a good guy but really I was like
you know putting down payment on a
future [__] session
yeah and I think that's true
to create boundaries I was going broke
dude yeah
create boundaries
I was lost at all that's like the
perfect way to phrase it so honestly it
really is I I have a friend that um I
was attracted to when I was single and
um she's in a committed relationship and
she wanted to work with me and I told
her no
because too [__] hot that's why and
I'm gonna get you to cheat on your
[__] boyfriend too hot to him you're
too [__] hot
and I was like no like and I feel like
those situations you gotta create
boundaries you do or otherwise she's
gonna get locked jaw yeah exactly do it
do it do it
you want this to happen see like you
want that really you want to be a billy
mouth bass it's absolutely dangerous we
flirt too much it's too dangerous the
connection's too strong too [__]
it's a fact what are you gonna do how
old is she do you know I um I believe I
want to say 20s oh just oh bro just
[__] tell them dude you're never
gonna [__] talk to him again you're
never gonna talk to him again because
you're gonna be somebody else and it's
gonna be fine and if if best case
scenario you end up with them and you
guys are both happy and great real best
friends don't try to get pregnant from
each other okay
real friends don't [__] each other's
mouths and [__]
yeah you can call your ladies your best
friend yeah nope just the [__] buddy
that's real alpha male baby just a paid
off [__] said
foreign